these days are interactions with
technology are increasing at a rapid
Pace from products like chat gbt to
automated phone systems we often find
ourselves talking to machines as if they
were human but while some of us might
find that cold and scary for others it's
exactly the interaction we need Elise
Preston has the story from Southern
California
this is the start of a futuristic
friendship for Luke Sepulveda in
different spaces you don't know how he's
going to react so I was just hoping for
the best Alyssa pulled it as
four-year-old son is on the autism
spectrum she wants to make sure he can
communicate with the world around him he
was locked into that robot yeah you're
smiling I know that's from the inside
out just knowing that a robot can engage
his attention that makes me happy here
at the Santa Ana public library robots
are specially programmed to teach
children with autism one in 36 children
in the U.S is on this spectrum that is
the square touch this Square this is one
of the first libraries in the country to
provide this pricey program free access
is a big issue especially to new
technology librarian Cheryl Eberly
launched the program during the pandemic
hoping to help fill gaps of services for
children of color who are often
underserved in diagnosed when they're
older every time I see you know a kid on
the Spectrum when you're a Divergent kid
lock in and interact with the robot and
get that that moment where they are
bonded and they understand it's amazing
bonds created with the human help of
Larry singer human beings have emotions
human beings get tired human beings get
frustrated a robot
same response every single time the tone
is always the same they're not critical
they're always comforting I am proud of
you oh
my hope and dream for him is really just
do your best you're awesome and you're
loved for CBS Saturday morning Elise
Preston Santa Ana California
now that's a reason for it thank you
you're awesome in your love we've been
joking about how there's so many things
with robots that get scary yes that's a
great way when you can reach a child
that maybe you couldn't have reached
another way